Hello, everybody. Welcome to another Zoom call on this beautiful New Year's Day,
2025. Welcome to a new year. Okay, let's get started. Remember, always look
in the announcements on the members page, the members home page. There's any new
announcements and you can always schedule follow-up call with the other page or
several other pages as well, or even on our website. And if you have questions, just
chat in your questions if you think of something while we're going through this.
All right, let's get started. Question number one, when looking at my genetic
testing, are those genetic defects permanent? So the answer is yes. So another
question that would follow up on that is, should I ever run my genetics
again? Well, for most people, the answer would be no, because those genetic
defects are not going to improve. Now, I remember when the genetic testing first came out
years ago, we were really one of the first clinics to implement it. I used to do
genetic testing for gosh, just, you know, maybe even a dozen people a week. So we've
done a lot of this. I've probably looked at more genetics than people most
practitioners. It doesn't mean I know more than most practitioners. It means I've
looked at a lot of people's genes. And there were those, there were
practitioners at that time when genetic testing first came out saying that, oh,
you can change a person's genes and making all these, these, these promises that
if you're taking this nutrient, you can change a person's genes and all this stuff
coming out. It's like, oh, yeah, well, just it's easy to prove that comment by just
running a person's genetics again. It's never been done. So yes, if you're
going to have, if you have a genetic defect, if you have a single allele or a
single allele defect on a specific gene, it's never going to get better. The thing
that can change, though, is that it could get worse. So if how, how, so the reason
why you have genetic defects are two reasons. You can have genetic defects because
you inherited them from your parents, 99.9% of your genetic defects you inherited
from your parents. The second way you can get a genetic defect is what's called
acquired defect. And that is, you know, a toxin, you're exposed to some sort of
oxidizing agent that damages your genes. That's the whole thing about this, this
COVID vaccine and the COVID disease is that it could be gene-altering. When you're
taking an mRNA vaccine, which is just about all the vaccines, our mRNA vaccines
now, it can alter your genes. That's not a good thing. You alter your genes
either through a toxin or a vaccine. Now you're going to pass down that altered
gene to your offspring. Well, it's okay. It's not a big deal because I'm in my
60s and I'm not having any more kids. Well, we don't know what it's doing to you
health-wise and your defense against other disorders, you know, in the years
that you have left. But worse, they're been vaccinated. The children with mRNA
vaccines that are going to alter their genes, then they're going to pass down to
their children. We're actually, we're actually ruining our species. We're damaging
our entire species. You know what's honest is I've looked at so many people's
genetic profiles that the people that have the best genetic profiles may need
the least defects are the older people. So typically the older you are, you think,
well, how's that? If you're acquiring defects by exposure to toxins, not all
toxins are going to damage your genes. So it is, it is though the older people
that were probably, you think, well, the older people they were exposed to more
toxins that they're like, no, for the first maybe 30 or 40 years of their life,
they're exposed to a lot fewer toxins. We're exposed to a lot more toxins today
that our ancestors were. Our great-grandparents probably had very few genetic
defects. And then the exposure of environmental toxins over the years increased
the amount of acquired defects that then were handed down to children. So when I look
at somebody's genes from say 75-year-old or an 85-year-old patient, it's like,
oh my gosh, this is the way it was supposed to be. And you look at somebody's genes
from a 23-year-old patient, it's like, oh my lord, it's like so many defects. So long
answer to the question, you're not going to improve those defects and acquired
genetic defect damage. It's going to cause defects that then will be also
permanent and be handed down to the next generation. Next question, how can
I increase dosage on antioxidants to make them cancer-killing oxidants?
So antioxidant versus oxidant therapy. And antioxidant is going to be something
that is going to help with oxidative stress. So remember any toxins
that we're exposed to can be our sources of oxidative stress that can then
cause damage to our cell membranes, cause damage to the nucleus of the cell,
and can be a cause of cancer. So oxidizing agents are typically not thought
to be good. Now understand, I've said this for 40 years in practice here,
almost, that everything is about balance. So you do need a certain amount of
oxidative stress in your body, even if you don't have cancer, you need a certain amount
of oxidative stress. That oxidative stress will help you kill pathogens,
so living organisms are killed through oxidative stress. They're also killed
through a immune response, but they're also killed through oxidative stress
to kill a pathogen inside the cell. Your immune system is not getting
inside the cell. You don't have macrophages intracellularly.
You don't have lymphocytes intracellularly. What do you have intracellularly
to kill pathogens that go inside the cell? Well, you have oxidative stress,
so your body is making a certain amount of oxidants that will then
oxidate a pathogen and kill it. Pathogen there readily killed through oxidation.
That's why most topical, you know, like hydrogen peroxide, first example,
why is hydrogen peroxide a great topical killer of like an infection?
You have a cut on your hand and you want to make sure it doesn't become infected.
You could put some hydrogen peroxide on it. Why? Because it's an oxidizing agent
and it will readily kill bacteria or viruses or pathogens. Let's try to enter
through that break in the skin. So it is in the cell, your cells are making
oxidants as well as antioxidants. So it's all about balance.
Now the truth is is that for most people, you know, that don't have cancer,
most of us are exposed to more oxidizing agents, then our bodies are
have the ability to create antioxidants and that can be a bad thing because
that could be a cause of cancer. Obviously oxidizing agents are a major cause of cancer.
But once you have cancer, now the tables flip. Cancer cells because they're rapidly
replicated are already at a state of high oxidative stress and we could understand
that information and support the killing of the cell by tipping it over by
causing more oxidative stress. So that's what this question is leading towards.
How do I increase my dosage of antioxidants to make them more cancer-killing
oxidants? And the question is asked because we've talked about
dose-dependent vitamin C. So vitamin C and a regular dose. Let's say you're taking
500 to 1500 to 2000 milligrams of vitamin C per day.
The benefits are it helps stimulate your immune system and it's a strong antioxidant.
But if you take vitamin C at a higher dose, the studies that are out there show
higher dose. I'd say you have to be maybe 4000 milligrams or 4 grams per dose.
Remember we talked about, if you spread out, well, I take 4000 milligrams a day.
So I'm safe because then it's more oxidative. So when you get up to 4000 milligrams,
you would say that that's more an oxidative stress therapy that it is an anti-oxidant
therapy. Still has the great stimulation of the immune response that we need as a
cancer patient but we're we're hard to see that oxidative stress piece.
But as we shared last week that if you spread that 4000 milligrams out through
the day, now you're really only getting, let's say you're taking a four times a day,
it's four hours a part or something. Now you're really only, now you can really only count
1000 milligrams of that. So now you're getting antioxidant effect.
So it is per dose, it's per, you know, every all supplements that you take,
they're going to have a half-life of your body. So if at any given time in your body,
you're only experiencing a maximum of 1000 milligrams and vitamin C,
it's really going to function as an antioxidant. So you have to take it as a one-dose pill.
So how will you increase those things? We shared the article that I shared about it,
and go back and look at the blog post that says,
hard-to-seed oxidative stress. If you just go into our website and go to the search,
and start typing hard-to-seed, you'll come up with my blog post from the article
that I wrote about hard-to-seed oxidative stress on certain nutrients to make them oxidants
and help kill cancer. Vitamin C and a dose of about four grams per dose.
Vitamin E, it's not even all that much. So if you're taking a pop E,
if you're taking even one of them is probably add a dose enough to be an oxidizing agent,
certainly two. Selenium, I think I have it in that article. I think it's 200 micrograms
and selenium, I can't remember. And then melatonin. Melatonin is another one.
If you take it at a normal dosage, I mean, nobody's taking melatonin as it is to be an antioxidant,
but it has some antioxidant qualities. But if you take it at a high dose,
so high dose melatonin for cancer, the reason why it works is because it works as an oxidizing therapy,
but you really have to be up at least 40 milligrams.
So I'd say 40 milligrams and above would be an oxidizing therapy.
A few weeks ago on the Zoom, we were talking about being sure to increase the dose
isn't coming into antioxidants. I might have been seeing vitamin E so that they will become oxidizers instead.
Should I be concerned about antioxidants that I'm adding to my smoothie, such as meringa powder,
or any alba, or ashwagandha? Well, yes and no, it depends on the strength of that antioxidant.
Yes, meringa has some great cancer-killing properties, but the dose that you're probably taking it,
it's not so much an antioxidant. There's so many nutrients that have antioxidant properties understand.
So it's not a matter of eliminating all of them. You're really looking at the strong antioxidants that you want to eliminate.
Now, I would say obla is a pretty strong antioxidant, so you want to make sure you're taking an extra scoop of that.
Ashwagandha, I would not say that's a strong one. I wouldn't worry about that.
Other strong antioxidants that I would say you should be careful about glutathione, obviously.
NAC, because that's a precursor to glutathione, alpha-lopeic acid, and vitamin C.
Those are your biggies that you'd really want to make sure you're careful with.
If I am in full remission now, I think I am. Can you test me for what I should do about my autoimmune condition now?
Many of you started with us knowing that you have a comorbidity.
It might be an autoimmune disease, might be heart issues, might be blood pressure issues, might be cholesterol issues.
We put those a little bit on the back burner because we're trying to deal with a very serious disease in cancer.
Now, if the cancer isn't fairly stable, state, and now we have to start looking at the other comorbidity.
We can test you for those things.
What would you do differently with cancer versus an autoimmune disease?
If I had cancer and an autoimmune disease, which if you don't already know, you probably do have an autoimmune disease.
Most people have an autoimmune disease, and they don't have a diagnosed.
If you're over 30, you probably have at least a start of an autoimmune disease.
What would you do if ever I said you treat a lot of diseases differently if you had cancer?
For instance, I have heart disease and I have high blood pressure, and I take the nitric oxide, and now I have a diagnosed with cancer.
Well, I would say you got to change something else for your blood pressure besides the nitric oxide, because nitric oxide is a very strong stimulator of Van Jafe.
Van Jafe vascular endothelial growth factor, and that is what cancers love fast.
We don't want to be stimulating the vascular growth into a solid tumor.
If you had a blood cancer, I wouldn't be worried about that, like a leukemia.
But even a lymphoma where you have a solid tumor or any other cancer with solid tumor cancer, so you wouldn't want to be stimulating vascular endothelial growth factor.
So I would lay off the nitric oxide while we're dealing with the cancer.
And then you could possibly go back on that if you're in full revision, and you're doing so much better, and you need to know the more concentrated I get your blood pressure down in nitric oxide was working in the past.
If you have an autoimmune disease, what do you want to stay away from?
If you have an autoimmune disease, you want to stay away from specific immune stimulators, like different herbals and vitamin C.
Even at a high dose, so at a high dose, vitamin C is an oxidizing agent, but it's still an immune stimulant.
So can an autoimmune patient take IV vitamin C?
Well, if you're trying to kill cancer, I guess the cancer trumps the autoimmune disease, so yes, you can.
But now, if you have to know that it can flare your autoimmune disease, and it can be you're going to use immune stimulants, you can flare your autoimmune disease.
And anytime you stimulate your immune system for any other reason, you're going to kill that what you have antibodies against first and definition of an autoimmune disease is you have antibodies against self tissue.
So yeah, you're trying to kill the cancer.
At the same time, you're stimulating your immune system to kill the cancer, but you're stimulating your immune system and it's killing self antibody, so it's killing your own tissue.
Well, you deal with that while you're trying to kill cancer.
Now the cancer is in remission. Now I might back off on my immune stimulants per se.
Now that's one of the what's one of the huge things I love about mushrooms.
Okay, so mushrooms, polysaccharides, they're immune stimulators, but not really.
They're immune modulators.
So mushrooms, the polysaccharides in mushrooms are really immune modulators.
They so they won't directly just stimulate a broad based immune system, which could then make my autoimmune system autoimmune disease worse.
They will stimulate my immune system to kill the cancer, but not necessarily to kill other tissue.
So mushrooms are immune modulators.
Most people with autoimmune conditions don't have flares when they take mushrooms.
That's a beautiful thing about mushrooms. So polysaccharides and general mushrooms that evolve immune to aloevia immune product.
They're safe on those usually with autoimmune disease.
Long answer to that question. Sorry.
Next question. How can I discern between feeling ill or sick?
Whether it's from detoxing or it's from a virus or an infection or something.
Yeah, that's hard because so understand. So if I'm detoxing, I can feel ill.
That's typically called a herximer reaction named after a doctor herximer who initially described it a long time ago.
But it's very common with people with gram negative bacterial infections that are killing that infection like Lyme disease, Lyme disease, the gram negative bacteria.
Has gram negative bacteria or has lipopolysaccharides in the cell membrane. That's what makes it a gram negative bacteria.
And when you kill gram negative bacteria quickly, you will liberate a lot of lipopolysaccharides.
And they're quite toxic and they can make a person feel quite ill.
Lipopolysaccharides can damage the blood barrier very readily and can cross the blood barrier very, cross a lot of brain inflammation.
It can make you feel really yucky. That's called a herximer reaction.
So what a detoxing, I can also feel ill.
So a herximer reaction really is not specific to lipopolysaccharides, but it's specific to anything that overwhelms your liver.
So if I kill bacteria quickly, if I kill cells quickly, let's say with the chemotherapy.
So one of the reasons why I feel so sick with chemotherapy is I'm taking a drug that's poisoned or that's killing all sorts of cells and it can damage the blood barrier causing inflammation of the brain.
But another reason is that it's killing cells pathologically, not through apoptosis, but through cell lysis.
So anytime you have cell lysis, pathological cell death, you will liberate a lot of what are called endotoxins, cell particles, you know, cell membrane junk.
And you're going to overwhelm your liver.
Your liver is like, I can't take anymore, I can't take anymore, go on, go on, go on.
And you got all this junk in your blood, all these endotoxins in your blood that can make you feel quite ill.
Also, if you're sick, you have a virus, you have a bacterial infection, you're going to feel ill.
So how do I discern whether I have a bacterial infection, I have a virus, or I have a herximer reaction.
Sometimes it's difficult because you could get even a fever with a herximer reaction sometimes.
So typically, if you did a CBC with differential, that's a blood test, complete blood count, it can be quite easy, because that will show you if you're dealing with an infection, or you feel sick for some other reason.
So that would be an easy way.
So if we had access to, if you're in my hospital and you came in feeling it, we'd do a CBC and a complete metabolic patternable with that CBC.
If you showed an elevation of white blood cells, over 7, 7.5, I'd say you probably have an infection.
And then you would look at the differential of this white blood cells.
And if you had an elevated neutrophil prepared to lymphocyte, I'd say you probably have a little bacterial infection.
I mean, if you have a very high white blood cell count, let's answer 15.
And you have an elevated neutrophil count compared to lymphocyte count.
I'd say maybe even need to consider getting an antibiotic.
If you had an elevated white blood cell count, like I said before, and an elevated lymphocyte count in a more suppressed neutrophil count, I'd say you probably have a virus.
You need to go home and drink some chicken soup and take care of yourself, either way you probably should do that.
So that's the easiest way to know whether I'm feeling icky because I have an infection or I'm feeling icky because I'm detoxing.
But most of us don't just run off and get a blood test.
It's just not that easy when we're not feeling well.
So there's other clues, okay?
Other people in my house feel the same way.
Okay, that's a clue because you're not going to be detoxing the same way.
You came from a party or you're exposed to a lot of people or you have more under a lot of stress or you know, there's other things that would give you clues for that.
Obviously, like I said, if you have a fever, it's probably a greater chance that you have a sickness from detoxing.
If you're throwing up, you feel like you've got the flu.
And then the other thing is if it passes pretty quickly.
So you had it for a couple of days and now you're feeling better if probably it wasn't bug or something.
So those are the things that I would use to help differential diagnosed between those two.
Can I eat nuts and or strawberries if I'm supposed to be on a low histamine diet?
The question of a low histamine diet comes up a lot because a lot of people will we test their cheek swab, histamine can be a driver of their cancer.
And B, when we test people's genetics, they can have a lot of defects other histamine genes. There's a lot of histamine gene families.
So how do I actually live my life on a low histamine diet?
That's pretty difficult to be honest.
So it's not about eliminating histamines. That's impossible. You cannot eliminate histamines.
histamines are going to be in your food.
So then what do I do? So you try to eliminate high exposures.
I have several good articles on our website on histamines.
So if you go to our website in the search bar, start typing histamines.
And you'll see several good articles with histamine food lists and about what I'm saying now about how to live on a fairly low histamine diet.
Because when you think about histamines, you got to think about a bucket.
You're putting it every time you're consuming histamines or you're causing immune reactions in your body that are creating histamines, you're filling up that bucket.
And you may not experience any issues or symptoms until that bucket gets full. Now granted, if you have genetic defects on your histamine genes, you're automatically just carrying around a smaller bucket inside of you.
But if you don't have a lot of defects on your histamine genes, you have a normal size bucket. You can think of it that way.
So if you have a lot of defects, you're going to fill up that bucket more quickly.
So then how do you fill up that bucket by consumed histamines and by things that could cause inflammation in your body?
Because one of the chemicals that are going to be produced by your body in a state of inflammation is going to be a histamine.
There's multiple chemicals in that array slurry of chemokines that will be produced during inflammatory process in your body, which is happening all the time, but histamines are one of those states.
Now if you eat foods that have histamines in it, together with other foods that are considered low histamines, that would help.
So okay, nuts, nuts have histamines. If I get to eat a whole handful of nuts or a bowl full of nuts, I'm going to fill up that bucket quickly.
I save with strawberries. I have a lot of histamines in it. So if I get to eat a whole bowl full of strawberries, I'll fill up that bucket quickly.
But if I put some nuts on my salad or a couple of sliced strawberries on my salad, I'll be eating with other foods, they're not going to be absorbed as quickly.
I'll pass through my colon without the same expression of bucket filling as if I ate them all at once.
It's spreading things out. That's the key. And knowing, you know, having that list maybe taped up on your fridge and like just being careful with that.
That's the whole idea you're trying to be as careful as possible without filling up your bucket too quickly.
I'm checking my glucose numbers fairly regularly and my morning fasting glucose never seems to get below 90, even with a really good diet.
What can I do better? There are some things that can help a person bring down glucose as far as supplements go.
Like Burberry. Burberry is a big one to help bring down glucose. Crowley and pickle in eight is another product that can help bring down glucose.
But besides that, what dietary things can I do to help bring down glucose levels? Well, obviously, you can go to the web and download a chart of foods that will be most readily be causing glucose spikes.
And those are foods that are high in what is called the glycemic index.
But now some data is out that if you freeze or refrigerate some foods that are high in the glycemic index, you're going to create a more stable starch that is not going to be
lowers that food on the glycemic index greatly, like even like bread or potatoes. So if I cook up potatoes up and then I refrigerate them or even freeze them and then I reheat them as much lower on the glycemic index causing a spike.
So looking at your glycemic index foods are going to be your biggest thing.
And then the other thing I want to say about this is, is depending on how old you are, how damaged your, your pancreases and overwhelmed your pancreases and produce an insulin and your cell membranes are about getting glucose into cells.
Sometimes it's very difficult for people that ever, no matter what they do to get even if they're on a full ketogenic diet, I've had people on a full ketogenic diet, they are religious about their food and they can't get their glucose levels down.
It just is what it is. So there can be so much damage to different cell membranes and the pancreas or combination there of usually that you're never going to be able to do that. You just got to do the best you can. That's the bottom line.
I had a CDC done and I was told that my white blood cell coat was normal. It looks normal on the test, too.
But you said it's really not if it's over seven minus nine point four. What does this mean?
Okay, so this is kind of what I was talking about before.
So normal. So there's difference about lab values. What's the normal lab value versus the optimal value or functional range. So those ranges differ.
And the white blood cell rate is probably the greatest difference that all the blood tests out there of what's considered normal.
So from a lab value, most ever every lab you go to can have a little bit different range. There's nothing illegal about what range they think is normal.
But typically white blood cell coat would be like 4.0 to 11 or 11.5 would be a lab value normal range.
But an optimal range or functional range of white blood cell coat is much tighter than that. It's typically 4.5 to some, some people will say the optimal range is 6.5.
I would say maybe 7 to 7.5. And then anything under that that would be a functional deficiency in white blood cell coat.
Well, you see that a lot with cancer patients that that are going through chemotherapy, but you can see that with people that have chronic infections too.
So a chronic infection. So let's say I have a chronic MC bar infection or something or a chronic herpes infection or chronic, you know, whatever active H.
Pylora infection or something like that, that can just drain your immune system.
Even having cancer for a long period of time could be draining on your immune system and you can have a lower than normal.
You can have a white blood cell coat with 3.5. And you have even done chemotherapy.
So that's not good for somebody who's trying to fight cancer. You need your white blood cell coat, you know, up there in normal range.
But what about an elevated white blood cell coat? Well, the doctor said it's not elevated. It's 9.4. And the lab rage is as it goes up to 11.5. So he said it's normal.
Well, I'll guarantee you 9.4 is not normal. I've seen people with chronic Lyme disease that have had, you know, that's that's common with somebody with chronic Lyme disease.
Not a low white blood cell coat, but an elevated white blood cell coat, you know, that's in the 9s, 10s, and they've had it there for a decade with chronic Lyme disease.
That's not good. And that's abnormal when I would consider abnormal. It's outside of elevated outside of functional or optimal range.
But what else can cause that? So you want to look at, so if yours was 9.4, I would look at, I don't remember if we asked this question, but I would look at history.
That's the benefit of getting this test done on a fairly regular basis.
Okay, so let's say it's December, and I had this test done. It was 9.4. What is the last idea of a CBC with differential? Well, I had a CBC back in June. What was it?
It was 6.3. Okay, that's what the optimal range even. So now it's elevated to 9.4. I'd say you have an infection.
And then you, that's what you look at, the differential look at is your neutrophils elevated or your, you know, your lymphocytes elevated.
No, no, no, no, those are pretty normal. But my ESNophils are elevated. Okay, well, then it's probably environmental allergy. That's causing this.
Well, it probably wouldn't be in December happening that, but I've seen that with people in the spray allergy issues. There's, you know, they have these horrible spread allergies and do a CBC and it might be 9.4. They're ESNophils are elevated.
So, but then you would look at that differential and see what's different between the neutrophils and lymphocytes and monocytes and ESNophils and see what if there's imbalance there that will help you get a better picture of a differential diagnosed. So what actually could be causing the infection.
Now, if you went back in your history and your history was all back in June, it was 9.2. And back in December last year, it was 9.6. That I'd say, you have some sort of chronic infection going on. This isn't an acute infection that you necessarily need to treat, quote, unquote, treat right now.
It's a more chronic infection. Like I mentioned, what you could see with live disease or even chronic HP lower I've seen that was chronic AIDS by lower I too, you could have a, so with a chronic infection, you could have a suppressed white blood cell if it's just draining your, your white blood cell code, or you could have an elevated white blood cell code.
That's that through history. I mean, you know, the last six months, two years, it's been elevated. That's what you would, how you come to that conclusion.
What does it mean if you have low albumin? So albumin is a protein that is released by your liver. So that's what you look at a complete blood code.
So it's one of your major blood proteins. And it helps to transport hormones around your blood.
Now, if it's low, what could that be? So low albumin and low total protein is also considered what's called an ominous sign.
So if I just didn't have diagnosed the cancer, not at all, didn't even consider I have cancer and I went in for my yearly physical and I showed a low total protein, low albumin, low globular.
Those would be considered ominous signs for home. It should make the doctor go home. I got to dig a little bit deeper and see what's going on.
So a person can have liver dysfunction. That's causing low albumin. A person could have cancer that's causing low albumin. Now you look for other ominous signs that you don't diagnose cancer over a CBC and a complete metabolic panel.
But if I had elevated alcohol and phosphatase with low albumin, that would make me question, you know, start digging into possible other test to run to see what's causing this because it could be a cancer.
Or if I had also my cholesterol without taking any medication or making any giant adjustments went from being 200 last year to 135 this year, this huge drop in cholesterol, that would be a huge ominous sign for cancer as well.
Now they're called ominous signs because they just say, home, something's going on and we got to figure this out. Hypocloridria can cause low albumin too.
So that's a possibility, but you correlate that with some other tests and I go over all those other tests that should help diagnose hypocloridria, the blood tests on my blog on hypocloridria.
And remember, hypocloridria is too hydrochloric acid in your stomach, which is probably the most common morbidity known to man and it can cause the greatest disorders.
So that's what you look for. So low albumin by itself means something, but we don't know what it means until we look at in correlation to other labs and correlation to other findings.
And that's the way it is, honestly, with a lot of blood tests. Okay, so it means something, okay, even like we said, elevated white blood cell count. What does that mean? Is that being a infection? Well, maybe we have to correlate it with other things.
So everything, all your blood tests are clues. They give us clues to something going on and you got to go to a doctor that is digging into the differential diagnosis of what that clue means.
And that's what I've tried to give you with the, I added a ton of stuff under the labs and testings piece of the member sites. I'll make sure you go to that and help you, you know, understand labs to help you unravel the clues when you look at your labs because we are fighting more and more that doctor.
So you're like, go and have labs ordered by your oncologist, they sell them go over them. I just mind boggling to eat. Why do you run them if you're not going to go over them? I don't understand, but that's just the way it is.
I was wondering if I smoke salmon. Is it all right for me to eat given by mesothelioma? No, you should probably just send it to me and I'll consume it for you. Thanks. Next question. No, I'm just kidding. Sorry.
So is smoke salmon bad for mesothelioma or any cancer?
I would say no. So again, anything.
So anything you could, you could, you could find an article that smoke salmon causes cancer, barbecued causes cancer using, you know, you're right hand to brush your teeth causes cancer.
Anything could cause cancer done in excess, right? So yeah, if you're going to eat all your eating to smoke salmon all the time, then yeah, that probably would be good.
But you want to use your barbecue to smoke some salmon by all means, I would say do that.
I have a new grill. I wanted to try smoking my own salmon. So it would control the ingredients. Absolutely. So I smoke salmon before smoke a lot of things.
That's a benefit. My son-in-law just smoked a brisket. We're happy that tonight. So all for using your, your, your much better off making your old stuff. So I'd say you're fine.
A few weeks ago, you said if we were going to do the Joe Tippen's protocol, we should run a complete metabolic panel.
So the reason why I said that is it can often lead to, because Joe Tippen's protocol is using Fennbedesol. So you're using Fennbedesol, which is dog dewormer orally.
And it can like any medication affect your liver. So we want to look at your alcohol phosphates, your AST and ALT most specifically.
I've been on curcumin forever. I just started the A-pop E, which is the vitamin E, burmarine and CBD oil. That's part of, this is all part of Joe Tippen's protocol.
The creatinine and the EGFR out of range slightly any concerns. So her bug is 23 creatinine is 1.6 estimated glubarular filtration rate, which is the EGFR.
FR is 53. So the creatinine and the estimated glubarular filtration rate are kidney function tests. So based upon your labs, your kidneys are strained.
Is it because of the Fennbedesol adding that? Again, you'd want to look at history. So if you have a history of your creatinine and your EGFR going up and down and being out of range at different times, then I would say stay on the protocol.
If boy, it's never been underage. I've looked at my history and it's never been underage. Then I would say that I would say you might want to pulse the Fennbedesol, which means maybe go off of it for two weeks and then back on again.
So you're maybe two weeks on two weeks off. You're pulsing it.
Again, I mentioned that Fennbedesol being a medication can affect your liver, can elevate your AST, ALT and alkaline phosphatase most commonly.
But it can affect your kidneys as well. So these are kidney function tests that are out of range. Could it be the Fennbedesol? It certainly could. That's the only thing you're really changed. Certainly not the supplements, but it could be the Fennbedesol.
So maybe pulse that. But again, I'd look at your history. So you look at your blood test over time. That's what you're looking for the clues.
And if you have a history of these numbers going out of range and back in range, and they were even out of range, you know, at the last test that you'd say there really isn't any difference between the two tests.
But within range of your last blood test, your last complete metabolic panel, and now their own of range that I would consider pulsing it.
And a lot of questions come in. I will get to your questions on the chat here too.
The added frequencies to my right program are two hours each for a total of four hours. I guess this is something that I should do during the day.
Is that what you would tend to be to do every day? Thank you.
Yes, if I give you some extra frequencies, let's say I send you a flash drive after a cheek swab test with a short program like a two hour program. Yes, that's just to do during the day if you have time.
So you have to do them every day. No. If you're just sitting watching TV or reading a book or something, should you be running the right?
Well, it probably depends on how ill you are. But, you know, if you feel like you're in a fairly good state of remission, maybe you're not doing the right fit all during the day, you're only doing it at night.
That's me right now. But if you feel like you're not doing well right now or you're not in a state of remission yet, then during the day, you should be running day programs too, if you have time.
You certainly have to keep that balance between living your day and functioning with your family and being alive.
But if you're going to be sitting and reading, then you should run those short programs.
I've read two different articles about avocados, one saying they're histamine activators and another saying to eat them as a low histamine food. What do you think?
It goes back to our history question. And this we get a lot because this not necessarily on avocados, but if you look at you Google low histamine foods on the internet, and you're going to get different lists.
And the reason is, is because if we brought foods to a laboratory to test them for histamine levels, it depends on how old the foods are that are that we're testing that is going to be that will coordinate to the level of histamines we find in them.
So if our avocados are overly ripe, you're probably going to have more histamines in it than avocados that are less ripe.
I suppose the only, I guess we could probably see that with every food. So the older the food is, the more histamines that are going to be in it. That's why lists are going to be different.
So again, I would say eat them with balance, eat them with balance, eat them with other foods, eat them with foods, other things.
So localized hyperthermia, heat versus intratumeral, immutal therapy, freezee.
What are your thoughts about each and could you recommend it? So cryotherapy for tumors or hypertherapy for tumors.
So both work, both have the ability to work, because whatever you're drastically changing the temperature of the cell, the cell could die.
So if you drastically change the temperature, higher the cell could die, lower the cell could die. And cancer cells are going to be more susceptible to death than healthy cells.
So if I could drastically increase or decrease hot or cold on a group of cells, some of them are healthy cells and some of them are cancer cells, you have a greater chance of killing the cancer cell.
Either way, both of them work.
When you do coffee animals, any special instructions if you have an iliostomy, can you make substantial oils like frankincense or lemon grass at the same time?
So if you have an iliostomy, you can still do a coffee animal because you're not doing a coffee animal to remove contents in your rectum.
That's not what you're doing a coffee animal for. You're not doing a coffee animal to remove contents in your descending colon.
You're doing a coffee animal to stimulate the vagal nerve, cranial nerve tend in the rectum. That's the purpose of doing a coffee animal.
Now, it can have side benefits if you don't have an iliostomy that you will, you know, have bubble milk to you could possibly clean up sludge if you could possibly, you know, help help with constipation.
But the purpose of doing a coffee animal is to stimulate cranial nerve tend.
The iliostomy, the ulital nerve tend as your vagal nerve. That's another name for it, your vagus nerve or vagal nerve.
And it stimulates your parasympathetic nervous system. That's the whole purpose of doing a coffee animal is parasympathetic stimulation.
When you stimulate your parasympathetic, you're stimulating your immune system, you're stimulating detoxification pathways, you're stimulating recent relaxation, you're stimulating decrease inflammation in the brain.
All sorts of great things you're doing when you're stimulating the parasympathetics.
Also, if you go to our website and you just start typing it in the search bar, parasympathetic, you're going to see parasympathetic, sympathetic exercises to stimulate your parasympathetics and other set of exercises to, to call your sympathetic, which are the opposite sign of that immune response.
So use those two. Can you use essential oils in your coffee animal? Yes, but I've always said that it's kind of a waste of the essential oil because how much are you, you know, it's mixed in with water.
If you're only holding it for 10 minutes, are you absorbing any of that? Are you affecting the cold at all? I don't know, maybe you are, but probably not very much because you're just avoiding it.
You're just dumping it all in the toilet. So I don't, I mean, you came, but I don't know if there isn't that much benefit tonight.
I also tried the cold brew version of the hot method. It seems that the cold brew is not as strong as mixing one tablespoon to about 10 ounces of warm water for the cold brew.
Yeah, if you're doing the cold brew method, if you're doing cold brew and then mixing it to water, the whole idea is that that caffeine. So that's the whole idea of using the coffee animal brand coffee that we sell for coffee animals.
It's extremely light roasted. You certainly want to want to drink it. It tastes horrible. It's just extremely caffeinated. So that's the idea behind that. So yeah, you want the caffeine as if you can tolerate it.
Okay, so that's the question you just read. I didn't get that. To harness vitamin C for oxidative stress, if I take four grams of regular vitamin C, and you want to eight grams in total, how should you time the follow up with lipozole vitamin C in four by one gram packets?
So if there are one gram packets, again, I think if you want the oxidative stress benefit of the vitamin C, you should take at least, or you could argue that you could probably say three.
But I'd say to be safe for grams at any given time, if you're trying to get eight grams in for a particular reason, you could do that all at one time.
But if your stomach, if it bothers your stomach, to take that much vitamin C orally, and you want to split it into two doses, just keep the doses at four grams each. Hopefully I'll understand that question right now.
I was thinking that, you know, if you're, if you're taking regular vitamin C, it takes a while to get into your system, but the life of somal goes in right away. I don't know.
And I was just trying to get them so that I would do the equivalent of eight at the same time. That was my intent in the question.
Well, the benefit of lipozole is you're going to absorb it better. It's going to be much better absorption. That's what you're saying.
So you technically could take less lipozole and get the same benefit of taking, or you could take probably, let's say you could take four grams of lipozole would be equivalent to, I can't remember the math on that.
But equivalent to probably taking 12 grams of oral capsules of vitamin C.
So yes, yeah, just the goal is you're trying to get, if you're taking lipozole, you'd probably only need, you know, two and a half to three grams.
It's their one gram packets, three of those, and it'd give a time to have that oxidizing effect because you're probably absorbing 90% of that with lipozole.
With, with non-lipozole, we have capsule of vitamin C. Let's say you took five grams, you're probably only going to absorb two and a half grams of that still oxidate a benefit.
So I think that's what you're talking about.
I've been taking 80 milligrams of lipozole today a day, but spreading it out never thought to ask if I needed to take it all at once. Should I take it all at once?
That is, I mean, 80 grams is fairly high dose. So I mean, it's split into two doses of 40 grams each, you'd be fine.
So yeah, so you just want to get, I think you'd probably be safe, oxidative stress with melatonin at 30 grams, but taking 80 grams is split into 240 grams, 40 milligram doses.
If you take an 80 milligrams of melatonin, split into two, 40 milligram doses and you're getting an oxidative benefit.
Since I've started the low histamine diet, as well as completely avoiding dairy, sugar, and gluten, my weight has dropped to 110. I started out around 125.
I eat a lot of good meat, eggs, healthy fats, veggies, and some fruits. I've been keeping my gluten-free grains to a minimum should I increase those.
I still feel good, and I think it's healthy weight yet, but I'm not, but I just want to check.
So it partly depends on what you think your healthy weight is for your body type, bone structure, et cetera.
If you'd say, if your answer to that was, well, when I was in high school, I thought I was really a healthy weight, and I was at 115,
well, that being 110 is probably too low. So then yes, I would then say you should probably increase some grains in order to gain that back, or some complex carbs at least to gain some of that back and to maintain that 115.
But if you would say, oh, I was in high school and felt like I was playing sports at things 110, I felt great at, and I feel good at 110.
Then I'd say fine, but you don't want to be lower than what you think your healthy weight is for your body type. That's the point.
So just look at what you feel like for your body type, what your healthy weight is, and you don't want to be lower than that.
Also, I would get, if you don't already get a glucometer, just pick one up a target or Wal-Mart or Wal-Greens or something with the, with the sticks, the test strip sticks, a test your glucose in the morning too.
If you're feeling good in everything, that's great. Also make sure, you know, the other thing that's common with a person that's a little bit low in weight is hypoglycemia. We don't want that either.
So hypoglycemia is your blood sugar spiking up to going spiking down, and you think, well, the lower the better. Well, not if it's going to these low spikes, because then it can bounce back up.
So we want it to be your blood sugar to be fairly level. So how you check for hypoglycemia is you'd check your morning fasting glucose, let's say it's 85 percent.
And two hours after you eat, just check that again once in a while. Don't certainly don't do that every day. You don't want me going through strips that fast.
And just check it. If it's like, boy, two hours after I eat, it's like 60 or 65. Then you probably have hypoglycemia. But you probably have symptoms too, but just keep watch for those symptoms.
Because that would be like a bit light-headed dizziness, just that feeling great. Those would be symptoms of hypoglycemia. You don't want that either.
That's common with somebody who's lost a lot of weight or they feel like they're a little bit below weight. And then the treatment for that is to keep a steady glucose level in your blood.
You have to be kind of snacking all day on something that's going to keep your glucose level steady. So just that's another thing to look at.
Back to the lab questions. I'm going to be making some videos like this low album. I was going to make some videos in the next few weeks.
And I'll have that up on the member site. Maybe make some blog posts out of it. Some different relationships, some different lab values in the complete metabolic panel and even the CBC to help you understand their relationship.
One to another to help with differential diagnosis of possible issues. So that when you do get your blood test done, you don't always need to make an appointment with me to go over it.
You could you could look at those videos and look at this blog post and help help understand the steps that couldn't that you could take to deal with it.
However, I said low album is one other thing that could cause that that is so common. It's hypochloridria. Most people when I test them, I put them on a product called clear digest or HCl side that they should be taking digestive enzymes with HCl or
probably I mean, it'd be safe to say I probably not be wrong if I said that 90% of people in this country have a deficiency in hydrochloric acid.
And it would be safe to say that that is at least a contributing factor to almost every disease we have because we're not digested or food correctly with hypochloridria.
That's causing issues, which is causing that inflammation, which is causing all sorts of chronic disorders like autoimmune issues.
Secondly, hypochloridria is a major cause for decrease in vitamin B12 absorption because if you have low stomach acid, you're not going to make it intrinsic factors. You're not going to be absorbing B12. So you're going to be 12 deficiency.
And then you are high candidate for HCl which is the number one bacterial infection worldwide, even according to the World Health Organization.
So an HCl is a major player. It's number one cause of stomach cancer. You could argue that it's a big player in every GI cancer.
And it can be a big player at any cancer. And it is a major contributing factor to heart disease. And heart disease is still the number one killer in the United States.
And you probably say at 99% of those people started out with HCl or I issues.
So taking HCl, taking hydrochloric acid with your food, with the digestive enzyme, just want to do it every meal all the time, but should be doing it every day, hopefully, or multiple times a week.
If you can't tolerate that, I have a whole series of steps to go through on my blog post on hypochloridria.
Cause some people have such damaged stomach that they can't even tolerate HCl, then they have to start out with apple cider vinegar instead.
And if they can't tolerate that, then they probably have a stomach ulcer, they have to start out trying to heal that with the glycerized licorice.
So I have things to do about that, but I will, I need to be making blog posts on a lot of the blood tests because I'm just fighting more and more people that are getting blood tests by their ecologists.
And then they're telling me that well, this was done, you know, four months ago and he, nobody's ever talked to me about this. I thought it was normal.
We don't want to do that.
All right, everybody, thank you for the great Zoom call. We'll get this up and get your questions in and we'll go over those next week.
Everybody have a happy new year. Hope your celebration was fun and we'll talk to you all next week.
Bye-bye.